et notre invité politique ce matin
c'était ni bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député de
paris délégué général de la république
en marche on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par pascal jalabert
nommé pascal dureau jours à vous et bras
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france on commence évidemment en parlant
de bernard tapie l'état lane de tous les
jours de tous nos journaux ce matin de
quasiment toute la presse quotidienne
régionale qu'est ce qui représentait
bernard tapie pour vous qu'est ce que
vous retenez de ses multiples facettes
d'abord ce bernard tapie c'était une
passion c'était une vie française
une résilience aussi à tout à toute
épreuve je crois que chacun petits bouts
de souvenirs avec bernard tapie au à
quand il ya eu les années tapie quand
même incroyable de se dire ça les années
tapie c'est à dire que c'est un bout de
l'histoire du pays aussi moi je me
rappelle un jour être tombé sur un
bouquin qu'il avait écrit j'étais très
très très jeune à ce moment là mais qui
s'appelait gagner je trouve ça
représente et bernard tapie voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui voulait gagner à tout prix
ça a donné aussi toutes ces histoires
etc mais c'est une france qui renonce et
pas d'une certaine façon et je trouve
que
dans le monde qu'on est en train de
vivre dans un moment un peu de de
bascule où on peut avoir des tentations
a renoncé à baisser les bras d'une
certaine façon face aux difficultés
voilà moi c'est ça que je vais retenir
de faire un tapis cercle qu'un qu'ils
renonçaient pas renoncer pas à combattre
l'extrême droite aussi mais y renoncer à
rien et je pense qu'on est dans un
moment on doit pas renoncer d'une
certaine façon ça fait aussi les
clivages dans la vie politique française
les clivages de deux déclare moi je
j'entends dans la vie politique du pays
une sorte de deux déclinisme
de plein de façons différentes
d'ailleurs à gauche ou à droite et nous
on incarne un camp qui pensent qu'on
peut bâtir à un chemin de progrès et je
pense que ça c'est important est
peut-être que c'est sale inspiration
marche du déclin mais juste parler de
son combat contre lui-même droite contre
le front national un cerexhe et 1
c'était le combat politique de sa vie
bien un tapis est ce pour vous c'est un
exemple vous qui compte devait combattre
une extrême droite est encore puissante
dans le pays oui bien sûr parce que il
faut le faire sur les sur les idées
on est dans un moment où quand on
regarde ce qui s'exprime dans le débat
public ça fait froid dans le dos d'une
certaine façon ça ramène aux années 30
dans le pays sur certaines expressions
certaine idée certaine façon de voir le
monde aussi dans un rapport de conflits
qualité permanent entre les religions
entre les français l'étranger entre les
hommes et les femmes berlin la piste est
l'opposé de ça il combattait non
seulement les dirigeants mais ils
combattaient les idées et je crois que
c'est très très important moi je veux
passer très peu de temps sur les combats
ou les attaques personnelles en revanche
je veux que nous combattions
inlassablement les idées de l'extrême
droite malheureusement elles sont bien
présentes dans le pays il va falloir se
relever les manches alors justement eric
zemmour porte-t-il ses idées pour vous
est il devenu le candidat d'extrême
droite tout cas c'est un candidat
banalement d'extrême droite
c'est l'évidence qu'ils incarnent des
idées racistes xénophobes
donc ce sont ces idées là qu'il faut
combattre je le disais tout à l'heure
d'une certaine façon moi ce qui
m'intéresse ce n'est pas tant les
personnes je vois des effets médiatiques
je vois une grande agitation c'est de
constater que dans notre pays il ya un
front déclinistes conservateur qui est
aujourd'hui incarnée par les extrêmes et
je vous dirai nourris des deux côtés par
les extraits d'une certaine façon ces
mélanges l'autre côté oui bien sûr
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
nourrissent ce bloc là un blog qui ne
parle de la france que pour en décrire
le déclin qui ne vit que dans le passé
ça me marque beaucoup c'est un projet
politique qui ne regardent que vers
l'arrière soit pour déconstruire ce
passé soit pour le glorifier soit pour
le tort de dévoyer d'une certaine façon
est donc je pense très sincèrement qu'il
faut que les forces progressistes du
pays celle qui croit en l'homme en sa
capacité à trouver des solutions à
innover à construire un chemin de
progrès qu'elles puissent se rassembler
parce que dans les années qui viennent
ça va être ça je crois l'affrontement
dans la vie politique française
vous en avez beaucoup parlé ce week-end
eric zemmour ans lors du campus de la
majorité présidentielle notamment
christophe castaner notamment olivier
verrons qui dans leur dit cours l'ont
beaucoup attaqué est ce que c'est la
bonne stratégie pour vous est-ce qu'ils
ont bien fait en tout cas combattre les
idées combattre ce qui représentait ce
qui met dans le débat public oui bien
sûr si señor ils ont plutôt convaincu
l'homme en l'occurrence de la cuillère
moi je pense que c'est jamais très utile
de personnaliser les choses voilà après
chacun sa manière de faire chacun son
style moi je pense que le plus important
c'est de le déconstruire cette idéologie
là nous montrer à quel point elle est
une impasse pour notre pays et je pense
que les français vous savez c'est un
peuple très politique c'est un peuple
aussi universaliste qui regarde ce qui
se passe dans le monde les français y
voient dans le monde le multilatéralisme
recul que les libertés des femmes des
minorités recule partout la france n'est
pas épargnée par sa stratégie
pour vous vous dites vous dit un petit
peu comme bruno le maire finalement que
de se servir comme d'un punching ball ca
sert a rien à ce que la stratégie à
adopter face à lui divise au sein de la
république en marche vous savez je ne
parle pas de zemmour tous les jours je
souhaiterais
nommé entre nous on fait pas des
réunions spécifiques pour savoir voilà
je vois la vie politique mais surtout
nous nous sommes en responsabilité je
crois que c'est ça et je plaisante
inquiète donc pas réellement je pense
que cette élection présidentielle sans
candidat à la présidentielle vous la
voulez souhaité ou vous là vous la
racontez vous vous rendez compte ce
n'est pas à souhaiter la candidature
d'eric zemmour pas peut-être à à la
limite la clarification des choses une
certaine façon mais je ne souhaite ni ne
redoute rien du tout concernant eric
zemmour en revanche les idées qui sont
sur la table nauséabonde jeu les combats
très énergiquement parce que je pense
que l'élection présentielle qui vient
c'est un moment de bascule pour pays
c'est peut-être une élection la plus
importante de ces verres azadeh parce
que nous sortons d'une crise qui a tout
remis en cause il faut tout reconstruire
d'une certaine façon notre pays peut
sortir plus fort de cette crise j'en
suis convaincu et c'est ce qu'on a
commencé à faire mais les gens ils
attendent aussi n'ont pas aller les
idées les plus les les plus folles d'une
certaine façon celles qui font le plus
parler ils attendent de la
responsabilité oui nous c'est ce que
nous essayons de faire nous agissons en
responsabilité pour protéger les
français pour être
raisonnable d'une certaine façon alors
oui c'est peut-être parfois un peu moins
sexy ça fait peut-être un peu moins
parler mais on est dans un monde où on
confond l'esprit de nuances et la
radicalité justement je pense que on
peut faire des choses radical au sens
propre du terme c'est-à-dire de
combattre les problèmes à la racine tout
en gardant un esprit de nuance est
responsable et aussi beaucoup de nos
compatriotes qui attendent avec un peu
d'anxiété les factures d'électricité ou
bien sûr ça jacent est vrai sans
carburant xavier bertrand a dit ben le
président n'a pas forcément écouté ceux
qui ont des petits salaires et qui ont
eu mal à arriver à la fin du mois que
lui répondez-vous départ je souris en
entendant ça y'a pas un quinquennat dans
lequel on est plus augmenter les
salaires justement de ceux qui sont à
l'entr'aide échelle que ce quinquennat
là on l'a fait en augmentant la prime
d'activité en baissant les charges en
défiscalisant les heures supplémentaires
ce qui fait que aujourd'hui un salarié
au smic ils gagnent 170 euros de plus
par mois un peu plus qu'un 13e mois tous
les ans avec les mesures que nous avons
prises le secret et moi je n'ai pas
inventé ces choses qui sont factuels
donc nous nous combattons justement pour
faire en sorte que le travail paye plus
donc ceux qui font des propositions en
réalité des choses que nous sommes déjà
en train de mettre en oeuvre c'est ce
qui fait qu
il propose des choses en temps c'est
l'impression que c'est une sorte de
porte parole d'une certaine façon du
gouvernement puisque il propose beaucoup
de choses effectivement bien que nous
sommes en train de faire ou que nous
avons déjà fait le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés là c est chose effectivement
dans lequel il est formidable avancée
dans son quinquennat mais le
gouvernement vous dites ça veut dire
en tout cas les propositions j'en ai pas
vu tant que ça qu'il a mises sur la
table sont des choses que nous faisons
absolument mais là où vous avez raison
ce qui m'intéresse davantage parce que
au fond peut se livrer à ce type de
débat chez pas sur ce qui intéresse le
plus les gens c'est vraiment de répondre
aux problèmes des français et les
problèmes des français c'est
effectivement pouvoir monter les fans
mois pour beaucoup d'entre eux ce qui
s'est passé sur l'augmentation des prix
d'énergie c'est essentiel et je crois
qu'il était important de répondre
rapidement ce bouclier tarifaires que le
premier ministre a annoncé c'est une
réponse forte et que je pense correspond
au quotidien des gens alors prendre le
pas son compte il est mauvais ça il
falloir continuer à le faire parce que
on peut baisser les impôts je crois qu
on le fait on le fait plus massivement
ça n'a jamais été fait sous la vème
république mais il faut rester attentif
à ces sujets là qui rogne le pouvoir
d'achat des français un mot sur ce
bouclier tarifaire justement parce
qu'effectivement ça ça concerne les
français qui voient leur facture
d'énergie augmenter l'opposition dit que
ça ne va pas assez loin qu'ils feront
des propositions dans le budget qui sera
examiné dans les prochains jours au
parlement est ce que vous êtes prêts à
les entendre tous les propositions ou
c'est le bouclier tarifaires et rien
d'autre les barreaux évidemment on va
avoir un débat budgétaire et tant mieux
et si les uns et les autres font des
propositions constructives il faudra
évidemment les écouter les débattre les
regarder attentivement ce que je
constate je suis et pas encore vu dans
quoi on fait attendre de voir ce n'est
pas une fin en soi non parce que parce
qu'il faut être constructif sur ces
sujets là mais ce que je constate c'est
que les mêmes qui nous disent que nous
laisserions filet dépenses publiques que
nous kraemer ion la caisse comme je les
entends du thon ceux qui toute la
journée nous disent que nous ne
dépensons pas assez quand on prend les
sujets les uns après les autres on qu'il
faut rester aussi raisonnable je pense
encore une fois que c'est ça
qu'attendent nos concitoyens
c'est une proposition très forte c'est
pas une proposition d'ailleurs c'est une
décision qu'a prise le premier ministre
que de geler complètement l'augmentation
des prix du gaz dans un contexte où il
explose au niveau mondial et ça allait
avoir des conséquences pour la france
donc ce n'est pas une petite décision
c'est le chèque énergie aussi le chèque
énergie s'était déjà 600 millions
d'euros sont des sommes qui sont
importantes pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français on va revenir à ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end du côté d'avignon est
ce qu'en plus de la majorité
présidentielle or c'était la majorité
présidentielle pas un mot de la
république en marche c'est fini la
république en maillot c'est pas fini
vous savez moi je j'assume parfaitement
d'avoir placé notre réunion sous le
signe de la majorité présidentielle
parce que nous sommes dans un moment où
nous devons rassembler toutes les forces
de la majorité présidentielle ne vous
inquiétez pas il y avait quatre mais
cinq cents marcheurs qui était là et il
avait la république en marche au coeur
et cette grande fierté d'avoir fondé un
mouvement citoyen et de continuer à le
faire vivre aux jeux reflet campagne
cette bannière wind ça va changer de nom
votre mouvement mais vous savez une
campagne présidentielle ce n'est pas la
campagne d'un parti politique c'est une
campagne comme on le dit sous la vème
aubry qui était un moment de rencontre
entre un homme et français le peuple de
france donc par nature ça n'est pas la
campagne d'un parti politique moi je
crois qu'il faut que nous rassemblons
sous cette bannière de la majorité
présentielle parce qu'au fond c'est ça
nous faisons ensemble depuis bientôt
cinq ans nous gouvernons ensemble nous
assumons nos responsabilités ensemble ce
qu'on a envie de continuer à faire et
vous constaterez c'est à la fois salut
christ mais inédit dans le paysage
politique français tout le monde se
divise tout le monde se divise même
l'extrême droite est divisée et nous
nous voulons nous rassemble et nous
voulons continuer de travailler ensemble
ça n'arrive s'est passé il ya eu la
création de l'ump en 2002 qui était un
peu la même chose le rassemblement de la
droite et du centre est ce que c'est ce
que c'est ça que vous voulez faire
finalement bien décrits sous la rubrique
marchés le modem dans un nouveau parrain
s'agit pas de dissoudre les différentes
formations politiques de footeux faire
des fusions acquisitions ou d'ailleurs
ce je constate que ça intéresse peu les
gens quand on parle de ces sujets là
généralement il s'agit de se rassembler
sous une bannière commune on dit parfois
maison commune qui permette à toutes les
formations politiques de la majorité de
se mettre ensemble de mieux travailler
ensemble de proposer aux français la
clarté d'un projet commun et surtout
surtout de dire ce que nous voulons
défendre ensemble vous en parlions et je
vous en remercie parce que c'est rare de
pouvoir parler du fond des idées nous
nous partageons un projet humaniste on
croit qu'il ya un chemin de progrès qui
est possible qu'il ya des nouvelles
conquêtes industriels technologiques un
scientifique qui sont possibles ça c'est
ce qui fonde notre identité commune on
va partir de là et ensuite on verra
quelle en sera la forme exactement on va
travailler avec les différents
dirigeants des formations politiques
dans les prochaines semaines mais
qu'elle
et secondaires par rapport aux fonds à
son tour philippe qui va créer son parti
en fin de semaine
figure-t-il parmi ses dirigeants avec
qui vous avez travaillé et doit-il
intégrer cette fameuse maison commune
cette majorité sont comment vous
l'appeliez oui bien évidemment et de
façon absolument évidente edouard
philippe qui a été le premier ministre
de cette majorité qui a dirigé cette
majorité parlementaire pendant trois ans
avec qui on a su bien travaillé et dont
les qualités d'homme d'état se sont
dégagés pendant la crise évidemment
qu'il doit être avec nous dans cette
maison commune et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il a exprimé les choses plutôt
clairement non
quand il a oui annoncé de façon
extrêmement clair son soutien présent de
la république ça a été une surprise pour
personne en réalité je pense que seuls
des esprits un petit peu tordu pouvait
douter de sa moi je crois qu'il faut
faire évidemment avec edouard philippe
c'est un atout c'est une chance pour
notre majorité on va combler l'ensemble
bien évidemment il est d'accord pour
intégrer cette maison commune mais il
est d'accord pour pouvoir constituer ce
bloc l'a ensuite ce que chacun souhaite
c'est que les identités des uns et des
autres là d'où l'on vient d'une certaine
façon c'est tendance à elles puissent
rester se manifester vive d'une certaine
façon pour que nous puissions avoir des
débats c'est juste moi ça me va bien je
crois que les mots clés d'une certaine
façon c'est l'élargissement c'est le
dépassement des clivages entre la droite
et la gauche et c'est le respect des
identités des uns et les autres si on
fait avec cette règle la haye cette
méthode là bas je crois qu'on venait
justement quand il propose la retraite à
67 ans alors que richard ferrand d'un
côté dit stop il faut arrêter de ne pas
rester réforme des retraites comment
vous fait le grand écart là c'est plus
dû au web et à non c'est vrai c'est une
opposition artificielle que vous créez
là
je sens que
je vais essayer d'être précis dans ma
réponse ne sont pas des petits sujets
pour les français un sujet qui sera au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle avec
cette clé du modèle social français des
choix qu'on fait richard ferrand ce
qu'il a indiqué c'est que son souhait
c'était condrey n'est ce pas cette
réforme dans ce quinquennat pour la
prépare pour la face au début du
prochain quinquennat ce n'est pas
opposée avec ce qu'a dit edouard
philippe qui je ne crois pas je les
bienvenus la panique il fallait faire la
réforme là maintenant tout de suite mais
en revanche qu'il faudrait la mettre en
oeuvre et en suit les ics ça devait être
la dernière réforme du prochain
quinquennat oui donc vous voyez bien ce
que je dis oui je le pense aussi dans le
dans le moment dans quelle nous sommes
je crois qu'il vaut mieux bien préparer
cette réforme et la présenter aux
français de façon complète donc rien
dans le budget de la sécurité sociale
2022 moi moi je crois qu'il serait plus
pertinent qu'un seul arrêt du sens de
présenter un projet complet encore une
fois pas le faire par bout d'une
certaine façon et que la campagne
présidentielle puisse faire valoir d'une
certaine façon la légitimité de ce
projet même pas les pensions minimums à
1000 euros puisqu'il en était un temps
question fait partie
notamment pour les agriculteurs et
c'était important de pouvoir le faire
mais je pense encore une fois que cette
réforme moi je préfère qu'on la prépare
dans le moindre détail qu'on la discute
avec les partenaires sociaux et la
question de l'âge que vous mentionnez à
l'instant elle sera dans ces sujets de
discussion oui moi je crois aussi qu'il
faut travailler plus longtemps comment
est-ce que c'est 67 ans comme
l'envisagent alors fini par lui dit 65
66 67 france et des discussions moi je
me pense que c'est aujourd'hui aller
trop loin que de parler d'un âge à 67
ans je pense pas que l'on soit dans ce
moment là le sens de l'histoire c'est
travailler plus longtemps j'essaie de
vous répondre avec la plus grande clarté
on est dans un modèle qui est
déséquilibré aujourd'hui il faut trouver
de quoi pérenniser le modèle la réforme
des retraites la faire aussi pour la
justice sociale c'est la question des
pensions minimums que vous évoquez c'est
la question aussi des carrières hachées
c'est la question différence de
traitement entre les hommes et les
femmes tout ça sont les sujets qu'il
faudra reprendre c'est la question des
régimes spéciaux faut de la justice et
la pérennité pour notre modèle de
réforme vous savez ce sont des sujets
sur lequel je crois que la majorité
présidentielle se retrouvera et sera
vraiment rassembler encore un sujet
important sur lequel on a envie de
ference le régime universel par points
il en sera encore question c'est une
autre réforme des retraites qu'il va
falloir passer désormais vous savez je
pense qu'il faut présenter une réforme
qui a un caractère de simplicité d'une
certaine façon on nous a fait le
reproche quand nous discutions le projet
de réforme qui a été initiée discuté à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il était trop
complexe pas assez bien compris il faut
peut-être en tirer les enseignements
effectivement et présenter un régime
simple de réformes pardon simple les
régimes spéciaux les pensions minimums
des mesures sur l'âge des mesures de
justice comme je l'aï indiqué je crois
que ça ça celle envisagée par les
français plus elle envisage il faut
toujours tirer les enseignements je
pense que dans ce cas qu'est là aussi ça
a été une marque de fabrique de cette
majorité de savoir le faire on parlait
des prix de l'énergie vous souvenez
aussi des difficultés qu'on a vu au mans
la crise et gilet jaune apprenons avec
humilité ça doit être une façon
d'avancer un dernier mot sur helder
filipe a après après on en parle peu
mais à avignon il a free il a fait une
vidéo il appelle les marcheurs à venir
samedi à vous y serez vous samedi je ne
sens pas un poète retraite à je ne sais
pas encore parce que je sais pas si j'ai
la possibilité d'y aller j'ai
disponibilité pour y aller donc je vais
me décider dans la semaine mais ce que
je veux dire de façon très claire c'est
que la république aux marges sera
représenté au havre n'y a pas de
difficulté avec cette initiative
l'autre sujet c'est la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui c'est la levée des masques
pour les écoliers dans 47 départements
ce hollow taux d'incidence est le plus
belle dans le même temps vous annoncer
vouloir souhaité prolonger le pas
salutaire alors prolongé jusqu'à l'été
est-ce que vous enjambez pas le
parlement quand même non je crois parce
lorsque les deux mesure que vous citez
là sont pas contradictoires ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens ces cas
avec l'amélioration la crise sanitaire
avec l'amélioration de la situation
sanitaire on puisse lever les
contraintes qui sont les plus gênantes
et les masques pour les écoliers pour
pouvoir apprendre à l'école ça faisait
certainement partie des mesures les plus
gênantes et donc c'est du bon sens
effectivement pouvoir relâcher la
pression là-dessus tant que la situation
sanitaire est effectivement bien sous
contrôle on va rester extrêmement
prudent les épisodes précédents nous
nous incite à ça d'autant que l'on
remonte dans plusieurs départements
exactement et puis une mesure de
précaution d'une certaine façon qui est
de conserver la possibilité de prendre
des décisions rapides pour pouvoir
réagir et on voit à quel point quand la
situation s'empire on a besoin de réagir
rapidement avec ce projet de loi que
nous voulons effectivement prolongé mais
vous savez comme ça avait été le cas
d'ailleurs dans le précédent quinquennat
sur l'état d'urgence n'ont pas sanitaire
celui-là mais sécuritaire où les mesures
avaient enjambé l'élection
présidentielle parce que vous le savez
très bien dans l'élection présentielle
le parlement ne se réunit pas et donc si
on doit à ce moment-là pouvoir prendre
des décisions je pense qu'il fera les
possibilités législatives de pouvoir le
faire mais notre idée est évidemment ce
n'est pas de prolonger pas sanitaires à
l'infini on n'est pas on n'a pas
vocation à vivent toujours avec ce petit
flash codes qu'on va aller justin las
calles pardon puisque vous parlez des
lois sur l'état d'urgence ce matin dans
le figaro laurent fabius le président du
conseil constitutionnel il dit qu'il
faut pouvoir contrôler les lois sur
l'état d'urgence avec le conseil
constitionnel doivent pouvoir le faire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais je
suis aussi favorable et c'est la raison
pour laquelle à l'assemblée on pourrait
avoir justement une commission
spécifique pour pouvoir interroger la
situation recevoir les membres du
gouvernement faut que le parlement
puisse continuer à faire son travail
mais moi je pense que c'est une bonne
existe pas oui on pourrait effectivement
envisager ça pour que parallèlement à
cet état d'urgence il ya toujours un
droit de revoyure d'une certaine façon
par le parlement à tout instant faire
non ce discussion qu'on a évidemment
mais prenons en compte la situation
particulière de l'élection
présidentielle encore une fois vous le
savez il ya un temps où le parlement ne
se réunit pas parce que ces scrutins je
crois que c'est un devoir de vigilance
d'une certaine façon qu'on doit avoir
par rapport à l'altérité commission
pour le prochain ça doit faire partie
des discussions qu'on aura au tour
l'examen de ce projet de loi justement
weir est un peu plus 7 millions de
français qui sont toujours pas vaccinées
ce qui empêche un peu l'immunité
collective notamment dans les
territoires ultramarins
faut-il à rendre obligatoire finalement
ce serait pas plus simple moi je crois
pas parce qu'on a eu un formidable
succès en convaincant en allant chercher
nos concitoyens là où il était pour
pouvoir vacciner et aujourd'hui regardez
la france est un des pays au monde où le
taux de vaccination est le plus élevé et
nous on a fait part la conviction par la
raison je pense qu'il faut garder cette
méthode là pour la suite évidemment
réussir aussi la campagne en ce qui
concerne la troisième dose c'est à dire
les gens les plus vulnérables
c'est cela en particulier qu'il faut
protéger je pense que c'est ça la
priorité aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]